uh there was another rally this past
weekend it wasn't just the crazy
anti-vaxx rally there was also the
completely unhinged more religiously
oriented anti-choice rally they call it
the march for life it's really the march
against choice against bodily autonomy
against allowing people mostly women
along with their partners who could be
male or female
to make decisions about what's best for
their health and their pregnancies
this is the very long long time uh uh in
existence now march for life
and
many of you are already familiar with
the endless hypocrisies with these march
for life people
but the good liars did some really good
work they went out to the march for life
and they interviewed some of the
anti-abortion people and they seemed
completely unable to understand the
irony and hypocrisy
of the things they believe here is a
really great example of an anti-choice
guy being interviewed about my body my
choice which he says doesn't make any
sense when it comes to abortion but when
presented with that when it comes to
vaccines all of a sudden he says yeah my
body my choice completely impervious
to uh hypocrisy take a look at this what
what message would you have for women
who are considering having an abortion
when when a woman becomes pregnant
there's two bodies there
it's not one and it's not my body my
choice oh it's
care for
care for the child there's adoption
there's
there's other routes to go
you know what do you what do you say to
people out there that that
say that they don't want to get the
covered vaccine
um
if the my body my choice works for
abortion why doesn't the same work for
the vaccine which of course you could
say the same thing right if wait hold on
a second if my body my choice works for
the vaccine why couldn't it work for
abortion like without a hint of irony
if it's my body it should be my choice
of whether or not i want to vaccinate
these people and the the theme here by
the way is a lot of just telling other
people what to do another really common
one is
never ever ever
abortion
because
there's adoption
and a lot of these people that advocate
for that they go well no i mean i'm not
adopting anyone but other people should
all right so here's another interesting
interview from the the good thieves the
good liars sorry i saw the sign choose
adoption yeah and how many how many
children have you adopted not able to
adopt
i'd love to adopt we weren't able to
adopt
and how many children have you adopted
none
i have two of my own yeah and how many
children how many children have you
adopted none
and how many and how many children have
you adopted i have two of my own yeah
but so you've adopted i have two of my
own
okay
the message okay so understand that this
is all about
telling other people
don't have an abortion ever
because instead you should pursue
adoption
and also telling other people go and
adopt i mean we're not doing it no we're
not going to participate in any of that
but other people should not have
abortions and then other people should
adopt their babies all about what other
people are supposed to do here's a bonus
this is jean mancini who runs the march
for life
saying that they have been praying and
fasting to earn or to end abortion i
didn't know that they were fasting take
a listen to this i have never seen the
enthusiasm of the pro-life movement like
i've seen this year it's like we have
prayed and fasted for years for this
moment and we're so
hopeful and positive that roe will be
overturned i had no idea that they were
fasting to end abortion now i don't know
a lot about fasting the closest i would
ever get would be as a kid
the first
two hours of the passover seder
felt like i was fasting even though i
had not actually fasted and until the
matzo ball soup came out and we could
have the food that's i so i have to
admit i don't know a lot about religious
fasting but i did not realize that they
thought fasting would end abortion i i
had no idea um every little detail about
this is outrageous and uh just just
rally after rally and the fact that
people go to this stuff really showing
us the dire state of the discourse in
the united states speaking of dire state
of discourse i have an invitation to
some of you
this weekend saturday january 29th
donald trump is doing another 2022 rally
this one is in conroe texas we would
like to hire someone from our audience
to go to the rally and interview people
live we'll be on a stream and some they
can they'll do some interviews and also
i will feed them some questions that i
have for the trump rally goers
if you so here's the deal we will pay
you we only need like one team probably
a one camera person or you know maybe
maybe uh one you might even be able to
film yourself but if you can get
yourself to conroe if you live in the
area and you can figure out how to get
in right like either you get a ticket or
you get a media registration we can't
help with those details but we will pay
we will pay you to go and do this and
you have the equipment which is like a
phone at this point basically
we want someone to go and do some
interviews at the rally for us so get in
touch info davidpakman.com don't ask us
how to get in
you have to look and see what the ticket
situation is like we're just it's too
soon to handle all of the logistics but
we will pay uh we'll come up with
something fair uh info davidpakman.com
ideally you would live nearby it would
be easy for you to get there um get in
touch if you would be interested in
doing that info davidpakman.com